Christmas came early for the Ukrainian
military three Russian Su 34 Jets one of
moscow's most modern Fighters allegedly
shot
down May every Russian pilot know for
sure that there will be an answer to
every Russian murderer said Ukrainian
President Vladimir zinski none will
remain unpunished but further Russian
punishment is largely reliant on
American Aid which is soon to run out we
have one more security assistance
package available to us before the end
of this year before we run out of
replenishment authority to replenish the
stocks and the inventories the Biden
Administration is hoping to give 60
billion worth of replenishments to keev
but Republicans have been holding up
that Aid tying new Ukraine money to
Fresh cash for border security even with
that strategy some senior Republicans
still support the fight against Russia
it's a dangerous
world one that doesn't reward
weakness America needs to show that we
haven't forgotten how to lead but that
message isn't Landing with the base and
the poll showing 62% of Republicans
think the US is doing too much to help
Ukraine up from 50% in July and that
Republican resistance is holding up
further attacks on Russia a top
Ukrainian General told Reuters that
account backed up by the former
Ukrainian defense minister in an
interview with NBC and we understand
that there is a political process and so
on it's just uh it's just like they need
to remember that every day or months of
delayed assistance uh that's somebody's
lives on state that the fact that some
politicians don't realize that uh that's
quite concerning I have to say but
Ukrainian politicians unfaced by
American political posturing I'm
confident that United States will not
let us down and what we have agreed in
United States will be
fulfilled a commitment to zalinsky that
will be put to the test in the New Year
Mackenzie gay Global News Ottawa